the Andrew what are you looking forward
to about Charlie and the Chocolate
Factory tonight I'm looking at a frankly
forward to seeing Doug Hodges
performance he's an actor I've worked to
the future both as a director and as a
an actor and he's a brilliant brilliant
man so I think he's going to bring a
whole new flavor to the part I like that
flavor who take look you see I'm a part
of I don't even realize it
he's done testing in there also it last
week he's absolutely brilliant okay
right so you you know that you know the
scoop that's mixing the city they want
to all excuse well we've got you here
because obviously we've got Sherlock
coming back and your character had a
very sticky end in that but can we look
forward to you coming back maybe as his
brother no that's what I can happen yeah
do they really give away the trade
secrets just because you've got a
smiling friendly faces I mean I gotta
give away the secret sure yeah yeah
because you've got lots of other stuff
coming up as well and one of the things
is lock it with Tom Hardy isn't it and
also the stack it's like this diet and
lock is is a sort of both quite small
films but and luck is a sort of a
thriller that's all set on one evening
and the stag is an irish film that um I
think has the potential to be really
fantastic I just saw I just saw a rough
cut of a John Denver it's really really
funny Irish comedy sort of longer lines
of fun little miss sunshine or you know
you comedy yeah yeah yeah it is awesome
it I think it's gonna be really good I
hope I hope now of course there's a lot
of talk about doctor here at the MoMA
and everyone's speculating about who's
gonna be after Matt Smith your name is
on the bookies list what does that feel
like on would you like to take on the
Doctor Who mantle well it's a very it's
a very flattering thing to to be
involved in in all those discussions but
and now I think nobody has to be way to
react we ask those things so yeah
they're very secretive I know mr. Moffat
very well so he'll keep his cards close
to his chest for as long as possible
yeah well it did him obviously you sure
yeah yeah yeah he's a brilliant
brilliant man I'm not going look forward
to you doing next what I'm gonna do and
I'm gonna do some filming actually I but
I can't really speak about that but I'm
just went to work work work with a
really exciting and British director as
soon and then I'm gonna do another film
later in the year and then I'm gonna do
with a theatre but actually at Necron on
Thursday night I'm gonna do a and I play
in the West End with Joanna Lumley for
three nights only yeah yeah yeah it's
these Pinter short Pinter plays and very
funny short Pinter play so I just come
from rehearsal and she's she's
formidable
and finally what do you remember most
about Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
on your kid either reading the books or
seen the movies I remember the drawings
quite quite a coincidence are so vivid
and they still are in my mind down and I
remember the chocolate River quite
considerably I remember how horrible the
girl the young girl was what's her name
again
violet isn't there's also very sauce she
blows up Ruka salt yeah yeah yeah I
relate to Veruca Salt
you